[Music]
far eaten it wasn't supposed to be like
this
go on Mac it's over there but if anyone
can set things right
Jule
I knew it would be you okay we're
looking for a power source it's the only
way we're gonna get our crawler back
online do you have the SAP Mac then
let's track it down
yep my EXO frame is working fine the
rest are recharging just like they
should
they're an opening at the top of the
cliff that's our way in
[Music]
why are you attacking us
[Music]
these core bot frames looks like the
scavenger BOTS have picked them clean
[Music]
all right let's make our way to the top
lead the way Mack
right behind you most people on earth
make the images of far even saw nothing
but rocks and sand but some of us saw a
future paradise whoa careful boy it's a
long way down
huh this door is missing its power cell
bot the little guy must be around here
somewhere
there you are let's get you back to your
socket
[Music]
Mack visit
hear that
this way Mac get back here
[Music]
a security lattice what's going on
max should be on the other side of this
door
Mack I got you buddy try it be more
careful we're not gonna find many
friendly BOTS in here
get down
didn't know he could do that
[Music]
that's the last of them did you see
their frames Mac they were all corroded
I don't like it either but we need to
keep going another missing cell pot I
wonder what scared them all out of their
sockets buddy over here Mac Mac dig in
don't worry we won't hurt you
[Music]
there feel better I know I hear to power
source must be close
core bots are much more intelligent than
core bytes but we designed them both to
be absolutely loyal and highly
protective of humans I'm getting some
really weird readings from that power
source I wonder if it's affecting the
other bots somehow
my extractor sugar in this war just like
before
up there look the power source it's some
kind of core if we get closer to it I
bet I can grab it with my extractor
Oh
[Music]
this will have to do this the hard way
first
this is the power source we've been
tracking never seen a core like this
before the view Mac the colors are mixed
together
cut me a boy you see that leg doesn't
look too bad
but I won't be able to fix it here can
you make it back to the crawler ok ok
let's go home alright Mac we got what we
came for
let's head back to the crawler